so the reason why this is it's not even fda approved so what's why is it relevant this one
is relevant because of the way it's designed and its unique qualities so it has a bivalent bcma
binding domain and it has a low cd3 affinity uh in addition to a silenced fc tail which allows
this to be given on a monthly dosing without having to go on the weekly dosing like all of
the other bispecifics that can then be spaced out so why what is unique about the cd3 low affinity
i want you guys to picture a light bulb so here we have six chandeliers that are all lit up if we
keep them lit up all day and all night the light bulbs are gonna go out pretty quick and they
probably won't last a whole year that's what bispecifics that are currently available are
doing they're activating the t-cells and they're causing t-cell exhaustion and they're causing uh
severe hypogamma anemia which can lead to infections when we have a low cd3 affinity
what's happening is that
these light bulbs are sensor activated so when we're here they're lit up but then when we leave
they turn off so that means that the light bulbs are going to last a much longer time
so that's the rationale of doing a low cd3 affinity for this study so how did this uh
bispecific get designed there were a bunch of studies to try to identify different modalities
and its killing activities so there was different affinities to the bcma to try to find just the
right one like Goldilocks and the porridges one that was not too hot and one that was not too
cold but it was just right enough to have good kill potential in the patients and then the affinity to
cd3 we all they also did studies to try to see if low affinity to cd3 versus high affinity to
cd3 would impact the efficacy of the bcma bispecific and we see here how even though
there's with the lowest cd3 affinity it is not going to impact the lysis of the cancer cells
in these patients but one thing that was noticed is that we are seeing less t-cell exhaustion by
having low cd3 affinity as you can see here on the very right where you have less markers of
cd8 exhaustion compared to the one that had high cd3 affinity and bcma so this led to the molecule
that we currently use formerly known as abvb383 now it's called the tentamic and the first study
that uh studied this the phase one was a dose escalation single agent without any step-up dosing
so directly to the full dose unlike any of the other bispecifics that have been designed and
here I just want to show the overall response rates of the different doses 40 60 and 60
milligrams on a monthly basis and we see that the overall response rate of 65 with excellent
depth of response and the crs rate is 70 with the every three week dosing at the 60 milligram and
percent at the every four week dosing so why is it less because with this particular uh um group of
patients we actually did dexamethasone the day before the night before they're giving the the
first the full dose or the first dose I should say and then we gave Tylenol for 24 hours for
the first after the first dose and this significantly reduced the incidence of crs
and it also reduced the severity of crs so if we look at that uh crs is only 24 percent
sorry uh crs is only 20 uh 43 with only 38 grade one and five percent um grade two and then if we
look at icons the incidence of icons is very minimal when we look at the medium pfs the pfs
was not reached at the 16 milligram every four week dosing and here other toxicities which is
something that we see in all of the bispecifics the neutropenia hypogammagoblanemia the rate of
infections the neutropenia is less
neutropenia overall when we look at the 16 milligrams approximately 57 well 40 43 with
every three week dosing and 57 with every four week dosing and then and this is at the 60 milligram
which is not the dose that is currently being pushed for approval it's the 40 milligrams in
combination with other agents and then in terms of infections we do have uh the most uh common
risk of grade three four infection is pneumonias with the rate of infection of
uh 19 which is much lower than what we're seeing with the other bispecifics so why is this could
it be the way the molecule was designed could that's causing less hypogammaglobulinemia could
it be that the way the molecule is designed and causing less T cell exhaustion is keeping the
immune system still viable so that it can fend infections uh it's hard to say too many variables
uh that we need to be looking into but the or is it that we're just spacing it out monthly from the
let go without doing the weekly dosing uh there's three different variables that need to be assessed
so we don't have an answer as to what's causing this lower rate of infections but it is there now
um hopefully we'll get it approved early next year but now just like all the other bispecifics it's
being studied in combination to see we can optimize the response rates that we're seeing
without increasing the toxicity of these uh agents so I just want to show briefly because I don't
want to take too much time because we've talked so much about bispecifics and
that are focused on bcma but we have the kilimanjaro arm that has a tantamic combined with daratumumab
and we see how we tested different doses 20 milligrams 40 milligrams and 60 milligrams
in combination with daratumumab the daratumumab was started with the first cycle of treatment
unlike other agents where the combination was started with cycle two all the combinations in
the kilimanjaro and combinations studies were started from the get-go in cycle one we see
overall response rates
um that are 83 percent with a combination at 40 milligrams and 82 percent at the 60 milligram
we're seeing deeper uh rates of responses and if we look at the toxicities the crs isn't really
impacted 29 of the patients had uh crs and the icons is also not increased and in terms of
infections we are seeing a slightly higher sign uh signal of infection with 67 percent all grade
infection and 26 percent
grade three and four infection this is with a medium follow-up of 12 months when we look at
the pomalidomide pomalidomide the combination with pomalidomide this study did have one step
up dose prior to the full dose it was given on four days prior to the first full dose and the
emit was started after afterwards so in this uh and this arm of this study we tested 20 milligrams
40 milligrams and then the combination we clumped everything we see that the 40 milligram the overall
response rate is 83 percent with uh complete remission or about a 55 percent and 81 percent
with the lower dose suggesting that both those could potentially be good this is for overall
response rate but if we look at pfs and duration of response it has not been reached but if we
look at the data that we saw from the single agent and the different doses we did see that the lower
doses even though they had the same response rate the duration of response was shorter so it's yet
to determine be determined if 20 milligrams is going to be as effective as 40 milligrams or not
another thing to point out about this study is that pomalidomide was forward milligrams instead
of two milligrams which other studies are using because we only want this for immune modulation
not so much for cytotoxicity and there was uh crs for this combination was only 35 percent
so in summary we're seeing that this atentamic is
a bispecific alternative to the three that are currently available with low affinity to cd3 that
helps reduce crs severity it helps reduce t-cell exhaustion and we're also seeing less infection
rates whether it's because of this low cd3 affinity or the monthly dosing we don't know but the need
for step-up dosing or the number of step-up doses is also put in question because we're seeing here
that we don't necessarily need to do step-up dosing and now that we're using prophylactic
tocilizumab or we're using dexamethasone prior
to starting treatment that could be another way that we could potentially reduce the number of
step-up doses with other agents and maybe those companies might want to go back to the drawing
board and do some studies on that and then the combination therapy with atentamic and other
agents is really improving responses with tolerable side effects but the impact on the immune
compartment on whether we choose dara or palm or another agent is yet to be determined thank you